monique parlez moi un peu de votre
situation chaque mois qu'est ce qui se
passe pour vous je vis avec le peu qu'il
me reste une fois j'ai tout payé ne
reste plus grand chose quand je peux
m'expliquer ça si je suis obligé de me
sers venus découvrir que j'ai à la
banque sans que ça coûte cher mais si je
vais manger si je veux me vêtir un peu
je sais où
bien sûr ce n'est pas tout les mois
qu'on fait mais j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin concrètement chaque mois
parce que vous avez une idée de la somme
que vous avez pour vous mais vraiment
que pour vous que pour moi je dirai rien
rien je dirais rien qu'en feront une
fois que j'ai tout payé une ré scor
voilée veut dire bien haut c'est pour ça
que je suis allé cogner à la banque
cette situation vous la vivez depuis
quand capuche est en retraite depuis je
suis en retraite avant je travaillais je
gagnais un peu plus que ça quand même je
vais donc j'avais comme 320 euros de
plus
je vais pas dire que je vivais enfin
comme tout le monde mais je vivais moi
je pouvais sortir je vais au cinéma je
faisais des petits week-ends avec mon
fils je vois là je sais tu es bien que
là maintenant je ne peux plus rien faire
je fais rien quoi je vivote qu'on dit je
m'en ont pas dire que je fais pas
d'écart je fais pas de trucs comme ça
c'est soit je paye mes dettes soit je
sors en soit je me paye des loisirs mais
bon moi je me dis il vaut mieux que je
paye même envoyé que je pence que je
dois payer tant pis pour ceux qui
restent à la fin du mois je me
débrouille pour hors jeu
je mange pas beaucoup alors ça va je
puis bon j'ai mes enfants que tu en
entends qui m'aide voilà quand on me dit
tu manges pas beaucoup ça vous a de vous
priver
oui oui j'ai eu deux jours j'ai pas
mangé
je n'ai pas dis à mes enfants et ça
c'est quelque chose qui arrive
régulièrement
voilà ça va mieux il ya mes enfants tu
mènes sa famille mes meilleurs moments
je m'étais deux jours pour moi j'ai pas
plus à manger que je me faisais un café
je trompais lui peindre je cache pas
mais ils ont une mise en forme on ne
savait pas où il vivait comme un échec
oui beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup tu vois
je me dis qu'est ce que je fais sur
cette terre oui pourquoi je suis arrivée
là de vivre comme ça j'aurais jamais
pensé son arrivée à 60,56 vivre ce que j
c'est très difficile
quand vous regardez un petit peu tous
partout que vous vivez au quotidien
depuis quatre ans maintenant
oui vous vous dites que s'il y avait des
choses à faire pour que ce soit pas
comme ça où vraiment pour le coup oui
non oui je pense oui je pense que que
les retraités enfin bon je pense que je
ne sais pas comment expliquer ça il
devrait augmenter les retraites comme un
peu quand même qu'est ce que ça fait
quatre ans qu'ils n'ont pas été
augmentés puis le peu qu'ils jouent en
contre comme le mois de janvier a
augmenté de 0,3 qu'est ce que cela vous
fait il trop suisse a calculé me dit
maman ça te fait une baguette de pain
non plus par mois si on peut quand on a
travaillé mon mérite de blanc a cotisé
qu'on mérite d'avoir d'avoir ce qu'on
ait cotisé quoi est-ce que vous avez des
angoisses des fois oui oui je suivis par
un médecin mais parce que des hauts et
des bas ce que je pense c'est ça qui
vous pèse moralement l'argent oui le
effet très difficile très difficile de
voir que mes enfants de med
ça me ça me touche tellement que ça me
fait mal même temps quoi qu'ils sont pas
là pour ça les ondées au fond et sont
ils sont pas là pour ça
mais si on était en difficulté que vous
pouviez les aider vous fait rire ah oui
bien sûr que je le ferais
oui bien sûr alors c'est normal de nom
quelquefois je prends mal il faut je le
promets je leur dis d'ailleurs que que
moi personnellement des fois ça me met
mal à l'aise mais je devrais pas mes
enfants ne devraient pas m'aider je
devrais pouvoir vivre décemment
j'ai travaillé du pelage de saison ouais
j'ai récupéré mes enfants mais j'ai
quand même travaillé et je devrais
pouvoir vivre décemment avec ma retraite
sans que mes enfants m'aident parce que
je suis aussi ils ont une famille ils
ont des enfants ils travaillent tous les
deux et on a des fois qu'il s'en sorte
pas mettre en rayon 2 quel message vous
souhaiteriez passé au président de la
république si vous pouviez lui parler
mais qu'elles augmentent les retraites
qu'ils prennent soin des d'extraits tait
parce que je pense qu'en ce moment il
est plutôt en train de les enfoncer
tous les retraités ne sont pas logés à
la même enseigne quoi il y en a qui ont
des petites retraites et nos points de
construire est tant mieux pour eux donc
ils ont travaillé pour ça je le
reconnais je ne dis pas le contraire
mais moi aussi j'ai travaillé je pense
que je mérite plus que ça j'ai élevé des
enfants tout seuls
pratiquement moi que je voudrais bien
que contre les retraites que l'on puisse
que les plus petites retraites sont
augmentés pour qu'on puisse vivre qu'on
n'est pas un ennemi à droite à gauche
mais je ne vois rien maintenant que les
gens puissent lui pourquoi
mais là qu'on comprenne bien vous savez
727 euros par mois pour vivre
quelle somme il faudrait percevoir pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'une aide parce que
cette saveur lycées et ses 480 euros je
l'avais été voir si ça doit être le le
minimum de l'urss est passé en tout
comme ça je crois
non non j'ai truc du rsa qu'elle m'a
parlé chez sa lettre le 480 euros alors
vous rendez compte
qu'est ce qu'une personne seule
j'aurai un enfant peut-être que ont
marre et aider mes 65 ans j'ai ouï avec
un enfant oui moi j'aurais pu avoir des
êtres je suis seul nom je peux me
débrouiller avec la somme que j'ai ils
ont eux mêmes été me dire qu'il fallait
que je déménage parce que je paye cher
de loyer
c'était ça dépassait comment je pourrais
dire le seuil de jeu pourquoi comment y
était trop cher par rapport à ce que je
gagnais par mois quoi tu allais que
changent de région on a été me dire ce à
quoi s'était pas une solution
ben j'ai fait des demandes ont jamais
rien proposé après j'ai lâché quoi je me
suis dit c'est bon quand parce que j'ai
demandé des quartiers donc je ne vais
pas aller à fontainebleau je vais pas
les frais si je vais parler
j'habitais fontaine de jeu déjà déménagé
ce que j'ai été agressé je suis arrivé
ici j'ai parlé aux grilles du palais
forteresse ni chez orange demandé de
quartier dans le coin je suis parce que
c'est calme on m'a rien proposé jusqu'à
maintenant alors je suis resté ici quoi
je vais pas je fais pareil à une logique
privée moi je relie la rue de déménager
miss volant il ya ça aussi ça coûte de
déménager je ferais comment c'est ce que
je dis aussi à mes enfants j'ai dit je
fais comment pour les ménages il trouve
patron de combien ça coûte
et puis il faut payer encore une caution
pour un nouveau logement enfin bon moi
pas proposé de le joindre
alors voilà quand je suis reste ici et
puis moi je me plais bien ici ça
quartier calme tranquille
bonjour tombe bien avec mes voisins
l'été c'est agréable enfin bon moi je
demande un logement plus petit un nom
jean lamour et puis comment dit que
bientôt il y aura pu d'apl d'après une
association sociale qui m'anime
inquiétez pas un gâteau il y en aura
plus l'apl germond alors que mon frein
alors si on croyait la paix la paix elle
sait ce qu'elle m'a dit un jour ce que
parce que là a ajouté au peu de
ressources dont vous bénéficiez
finalement on vous a également baissé
votre mois de janvier là oui moi
d'essayer mon apn cherche une aide de la
caf enfin la même de la caf qui me dit
qu'il me blesser encore mon apn
mais pour ça vous avez des explications
savez pourquoi ils disent que ce sont
mes revenus alors que je touche une
retraite je te la retraite n'a pas
augmenté depuis l'année dernière parce
qu'il n'ya pas eu d'augmentation des
retraites
j'ai pas gagner plus aujourd'hui votre
quotidien pour quelqu'un qui ne comprend
pas parce qu'il n'est pas confronté à
même chose que vous comment vous le
décrire
hakim est à notre place
que des gens qui nous prennent pour des
cassos moment où j'étais comme ça m'a
fait des enfants m'ont amené à
travailler c'est autre chose c'est pas
une caste mais d'un moment je me prenais
pour une classe hausse parce que je ne
m'en sors pas et voilà je je me suis
rabaissé et je voudrais que ces gens là
quand une vie facile qui se mettait à la
place des autres ces gens qui qui en bas
avec si peu de retraite ou les salaires
la khadra du moins il s'en sort pas
qu'ils y arrivent pas à quoi faut qu'ils
se mettre dedans qui viennent vivre avec
ce jour là pour voir comment il faut s'y
verront merci vous pouviez leur décrire
votre quotidien pour qu'ils se mettent à
votre place qu'est ce que vous la
retirez votre journée c'est quoi la
journée c'est quoi ben c'est me lever le
matin pour le mon petit déjeuner faire
mon ménage
pas grand chose quand l'après midi
danses et c soit je reste chez moi parce
que manger pas je peux pas sortir parce
que moi j'ai pas d'argent pour aller
unis boire un café une quelque chose
comme ça et c soit je my hair je prends
l'air soit je reste chez moi je cache
pas que des fois je rumine
mais des fois je prends je me pends - je
me dis non il faut pas que je suis comme
ça il faut que je sorte il faut que
j'aille kong l'air sinon dans ma tête ça
va pas aller quoi tu prends sur moi mais
des moments où je n'ai pas du tout envie
de sortir je reste chez moi fermé l'âge
ça fait trois jours que je suis enfermée
chez moi
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'il ya des
moments on avait plus envie sortir
pourquoi toujours marcher marcher marché
digère seul et puis marcher marcher
c'est bien marché mais des fois on en
rit ben idir maintiendrait bien quelque
part boire un café quoi vivent hors du
monde
voilà je sais pas j'ai changé quand on
peut même pas quoi on peut même pas dire
voilà on pourrait peut-être aller
s'acheter une petite pâtisserie un petit
truc voilà je vais chez le boulanger du
foie je fais des belles pâtisserie
gilbert fronton n'aura pas aujourd'hui
tout est bon pain puis voilà c'est tout
merci j'aimerais bien de temps en temps
pour me l'offrir
de temps en temps je pense que je le
mérite oui je le mérite et mensah on
peut pas quoi c'est ça c'est dur c'est
difficile ça fait combien de temps que
vous n'avez pas pris soin de vous juste
de vous les cheveux les vêtements
typiques
quand je vais chez le coiffeur c'est en
modèle parce que je paye pas mais ça
fait bien longtemps que je n'ai pas été
sur deux mois pour laurent depuis ma
retraite avant quand je travaillais je
me permettait d'aller je vais citer
scène pour les sourciers le tout sans
les épilations maintenant je ne vais
plus fait tout moi même je vais je peux
pas je peux pas le coiffeur j'y vais je
dire aux modèles la recherche des
modèles d'antan givet les couleurs c'est
moi qui les fais moi même
avant j'allais chez le coiffeur s'est
pourvu que j'avais chez les coiffeurs
quand je travaillais j'allais chez
jean-louis la guide ne sais pas je suit
le nous
c'est quand même un bon salon je me
faisais ma couleur et la coupe chez eux
quand je travaillais maintenant j'ai
plus depuis que je suis en retraite je
ne vais plus je n'y vais plus je
n'allais une fois par mois quand je
travaillais oui je faisais tout ça
maintenant je fais plus tout ça je vais
plus mon jeu peut peser 10 active
quand vous avez un travail que ça allait
bien est ce que vous imaginez que ça
puisse changer comme ça après non non
non je n'aurais jamais j'aurais pensé
que je dis aussi à mes enfants et jamais
je réponds c'est arrivé à la piètre
comme ça moi je n'aurais jamais pensé
vous avez toujours travaillé oui oui oui
tu traites vous n'aviez pas travailler
vous serez en grande détresse encore
plus mais plus oui je le reconnais il
avait des gens autour de vous pour en
parler qui vivent la même chose que vous
soutenir qu'il y ait de la même chose
que mon nom parce que bon ben je pige de
retraite que moi ils ont ils font des
voyages enfin cdg rembourser ma famille
c'est mon frère ma soeur tous que ce
retraite que moi mais mon frère me
comprend beaucoup et c'est que ce que
c'est que dans une famille de douze
enfants rend ses confrères reconnaît que
je vis avec eux rien quoi que je peux
rien faire voilà obligé pour vous dire
il ya pas longtemps à cette fête son
anniversaire j'ai été invité j'ai voulu
apporter un cadeau parce que je n'aime
pas je suis comme ça et il connaît ma
situation lors il dit surtout je te
préviens que non mais non rien j'ai
besoin de rien je sais que c'est
difficile pour toi le tas d'ossements
passe principal c'est que tu sois là
mais c'est du c'est difficile aussi pour
moi quand je vais et blanc et puis que
joueur les enfants d'offrir des cadeaux
au papa et moi je suis à éviter je donne
rien je me sens un peu c'est difficile
pour moi ce qu'avant je ne connaissais
pas ce à quoi
non ce que vous est déjà arrivé enfin
vous a dit je vais bénéficier je sais
pas moi de des restos du coeur ou des
fichiers pas droit aux restos du coeur
geniez peindront pour si j'avais un
enfant je réponds à plein de choses mais
moi je n'ai pas d'enfants mais j'ai trop
envie
donc j'ai même pas eu un respect du
calendrier du tout à 65 ans on n'a plus
grand chose à charge
oui bah non c'est à dire que vous pensez
qu'il n'existe rien aucune structure il
ya rien organismes ou non et jour non
qui ont passé l'âge finalement non y'a
rien y'a rien n'a rien
hmm hmm je vois je parle de dijon ce que
j'avais dit ion je vois ma soeur à la
vie dans un petit village à les
retraités et il ya un centre papa
récente pas un terrain pour les
personnes âgées qui se retrouvent une
fois par semaine ils font des gâteaux il
faut de la couture du tricot et
discutent ensemble ils font des choses
comme ça à dijon il ya pas ça il reste à
moi j'irai ça me ferait du bien
d'ailleurs ça fait du bien de rencontrer
des audiences c'est chez quelqu'un
d'arnon chez quelqu'un qui parle
facilement aux autres quand je vais pas
de différence entre qui que ce soit et
les religions y a rien n'est rien pour
les pour les personnes âgées pour les
pour nous irin
repas de noël ça fait deux ans que je
demande pour y aller combes refuse ben
non et puis deux places après l'annoncé
67 ans et à 65 ans ça fait deux fois que
je demande les comme non oui bon je suis
supporter du dfco confie c'était là
j'allais voir les matchs avec moi c'est
lui qui paye m
mon truc depuis qu'il est parti j'avais
plus ça fait trois ans et demi qu'il est
plus là je ne sais pas je n'y vais plus
je regarde à la télé où je regarde sur
mon portable les résultats mais je
devais plus je peux pas j'ai pas parce
que les prix sont trop chers
mais c'est pour ça qu'ils gagnent plus
et ils ont gagné samedi
mais moi je sais que j'ai peut-être
allez pouvoir paris dijon paris indexé
au pari parce que mon fils a acheté des
places et très longtemps au dr je crois
il pensait pouvoir gagner parce que le
match était repoussée et il pensait
pouvoir il est venu pour voir ce match
et en fin de compte le match n'a pas eu
lieu
il avait acheté des places pour lui une
place pour moi alors il m'a dit maman au
mois de mars
tu pourras y aller tu as ta place pour
aller là-bas il m'en reste une je vais
rien qui je la donnerai c'est pour que
la personne accompagnée tu ira voir le
match nice et à ton billet pour y aller
je suis content que je sais que j'ai
réparé le linge de lit et ses eaux
ça me fait du bien
non mais je ne fais plus rien de tout ça
je dis même un café des fois c'est dit
c'est pour moi je peux pas l'impression
d'être une autre femme car oui oui j'ai
beaucoup vieilli d'ailleurs je dis à mes
enfants je me laisse beaucoup aller
qu'est ce qui fait que j'ai ce sentiment
là est différente parce que je me laisse
beaucoup aller je sais pas une personne
comme ça ma part et je me laisse
beaucoup aller je suis me coquette je
suis moi j'ai pas les moyens
je suis moins coquette qu'avant je me
maquillais jeter quelqu'un de toujours
bien maintenant c'est plus possible dit
il quand même merci mais bon vous avez
beau milieu de l'hiver
oui c'est du beau sourcils bien dessinée
assise je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait et
j'ai pas de rides main un petit peu
malin maintenant je vous promets mais
j'ai quand même beaucoup gili en 90 ans
c'est moral surtout weeping bah oui pour
ceux du souci toujours maintenant
comment s'en sortir puis bon des fois je
lui ai dit j'aimerais bien ça j'aimerais
bien ça mais non en fin de compte tu
peux pas quoi
puis quand je pars au portugal mais je
suis content de xiu xiu xiu la barre
monfils prend soin de moi même si
travailler moi j'ai quand même ça n'a
pas je sors quand même je dois portugais
mais je me débrouille et messieurs
heureuse je suis jamais malade que j'ai
jamais rien je ne mettrai jamais quand
je suis arrivé ici je veux je peux mieux
jeudi au mont fuji j'arrive à dix jours
je ne suis pas bien j'ai mal à la tête
du mal au ventre je suis pas bien est ce
que dans ces quatre
de retraite il ya un jour où vous êtes
senti super bien malgré tout audi au
début c'est tout au début au début parce
que j'étais fatigué bon j'étais content
d'être là j'étais fatigué je me dis bon
bah c'est bien je dois me reposer mais
après quand j'ai eu ma retraite bon ben
moi je vous ai dit j'ai un petit peu
d'argent je les vois je
je les prix parce que j'en ai eu besoin
d'un ça allait encore mais après moi
quand je me suis retrouvé avec plus rien
que mon économie bcm un jeu c'est là que
ça commence et je me dis il faut que je
fasse avec que ce que j'ai fait avant
que vous êtes directive votre salaire
ils étaient suffisants pour vivre mais
pas assez pour mettre de côté je m'étais
50 euros par mois deux côtés maintenant
je peux pas je peux même pas ici demain
vous à une tuile mécanique
j'ai pensé chine importe quoi comment
vous faites face ben je sais pas s'il
faut que j'achète ma machine à crédit
comme les crédits sur le dos parce que
je serai pas les moyens de me la payer
j'aime bien la vie ça coûte cher mais je
pense aussi
si un jour il m'arrive quelque chose de
grand mais en font qu'on les enfants
feront quoi j'ai une assurance à la
banque mais ça suffit je pense pas que
ça suffira pour une des mises en font si
mal donc ça aussi j'y pense j'ai peur de
vieillir j'ai peur de moi je vais perdre
tout ça et puis tombé gravement malade
qui m'arrive quelque chose
comment feront mes enfants pour ce venir
avaient si je décède par exemple comment
feront mes enfants pour supporter tout
ça j'y pense aussi pourquoi mes enfants
exercice difficile aussi vous sentez
seul dans cette situation
oui et oui
quand vous vous réfléchissez à tout ça
vous avez de l'espoir quand même que ça
change un jour
non mais on n'est plus non je resterai
comme ça j'ai plus de l'espoir je n'ai
plus maintenant plus on y lit monadé
cependant je trouve je puisse comme ça
nous avait songé à quand une profession
malgré le fait que vous aviez l'âge des
trains retraite
oui j'ai je voulais faire quelque chose
mais j'avais commencé j'ai retourné dans
mon travail j'étais un bon on va
proposer de travailler mais bon après on
vous donne d'argent d'un côté vous
gagnez ça mais d'un autre côté on vous
enlève comme moi ce qui m'est arrivé
j'ai pas eu d'appel parce que on va dit
j'avais travaillé j'ai dépassé j'ai
travaillé quelques mois et demi vous
rendez compte si je travaille toute
l'année
j'appuie la pl excusez moi j'aurais pu
la payer
je peux pas je pourrai pas payer un
loyer de 500 euros donc je vois combien
450 je pourrais pas mais finalement
c'est ça
ma vie c'est quand j'ai vu ça après que
quand j'ai travaillé que j'ai vu que mon
nouvel apn et je me suis dit bon
maintenant c'est long je ne travaillerai
plus on peut me rappeler je n'aurais je
retournerai plus ça sert à rien ça sert
à rien parce que bon ça m'enfonce plus
qu'autre chose
pourtant j'étais contente d'avoir
retourné travailler quand on m'a proposé
j'étais content parce que j'ai retrouvé
mes collègues je vais retrouver un
semblant de vie parce que je me levais
le matin j'avais travaillé je voyais des
gens je m'appuie j'aimais bien mon
travail surtout voilà je m'entendais
bien avec ma collègue mon travail me
plaisait beaucoup
alors j'étais contente mais c'est après
quand on vous recevez salles l'année
d'après en janvier que vous recevez un
truc qui me dit bon voilà vous avez
gagné ton dans l'année vous avez plus
droit quoi parce que j ai dépassé
après je me suis dit non je ne ferai
plus je fais plus vous allez marcher
jeudi avec les autres oui bien sûr oui
j'y vais je sais pas quelle heure que
c'est ce qu'il n'y a rien dans les
journaux c'est en début de l'après midi
je vais vous le dire je n'ai jeu très
bien ce que mon ami va demander aussi
leur parce que c'est il pourrait
peut-être venir aussi c'est important
pour vous tous mobilisés dans la rue je
dis oui j'ai déjà été il ya déjà eu des
choses j'ai déjà été mais j'ai pas osé
parler à des gens cette fois là j'y suis
allé j'ai pas besoin leur parler mais de
là demain si j'y vais ici je pense que
j'ai mais je vais aller de l'avant je
vais aller vers eux mais je pense qu'il
y en a sûrement qui doivent être dans la
même situation que moi peut-être pire
cci jeu samedi j'irai avec qui j'ai les
jambes
c'est une façon pour vous de montrer que
vous existe
je puis il ya ça aussi ce que je pense
que le gouvernement pour les pour les
retraités y arrive quoi il les met de
côté
il est oublié je pense pour certaines
catégories les yogis les pauvres petits
retraités comment par exemple quand vous
vous êtes en colère
oui oui
oui parce que les gens qu'on travaille
et je pense qu'il mérite salaire
ils sont retrouvés vers est de vivre
décemment de vivre avec derrière les
petits bouts comme moi je me répète
encore il n'a pire que moi j'en ai
entendu parler
il n'ya pas pire que moi alors des fois
je me dis bien ces gens là comment ils
font moi je les chargements je m'en sors
pas ces pauvres gens comment ils font
c'est moi tu vois ce que je veux dire
que vous avez envie de dire qu'on n'a
pas abordé
non
merci en tout cas d'avoir partagé tous à
luynes doute que c'est pas facile non
mais je suis certaine
et ça je lis le plus sincèrement bien
que c'est un témoignage qui va qui va
fédérer beaucoup de gens j'espère
j'espère aussi bien pour moi que pour
les autres personnes c'est qu'ils sont
dans la même situation qu'au mans mais
c'est très courageux mais centrait mais
ce n'est rien